I sat last night with Olive, and we were reading
the latest in the "She persisted," series.
I am such a fan of these books.
This one is science.
Yes.
I want young readers to think, oh my gosh,
I can go off and discover amazing things is about animals
I might not even know yet, like Jane Goodall,
or I can have amazing scientific discoveries
like Rosalind Franklin.
I've found so many of the kids that read early versions
of "She Persisted in Science,"
were actually particularly drawn to Flossie Wong-Staal
and to Rosalind Franklin, because their work
has also helped us understand COVID.
Yeah.
And has helped in the
development of the COVID-19 vaccines.
And so I think it also is just great for kids to understand,
oh my gosh, these incredible things that women did
decades ago are now mattering to my life,
are now helping to save people's lives today.
And I appreciated reading-
(audience applauding)
A children's book which very much for any age,
and they're just so illuminating
about what women, extraordinary women, have done.
It's so celebratory, it's so inspirational.
So when I was reading the book with my children,
in an earlier version, my son Aidan, who's five,
was fascinated with Gladys West who helped invent GPS.
Yes!
And he was like,
"What? You used to not know where you were going?"
And I was like, "Yes, way back when I was your age,
we got lost sometimes."
(audience laughing)
He couldn't believe that there was a...
He was like, "You didn't have a phone with a map on it?"
And I was like, "No, I didn't even have a phone."
I was like, "Oh my gosh, how much has changed?"
So much is changing.
Now, how did you get that resource?
How did you get that memo that there was nothing
you couldn't do, or did you feel like that as a kid?
My mom and I have talked about this question a lot,
because when I was growing up in Little Rock, in Arkansas,
in the '80s and '90s, I had my mom as a role model.
I also had most of my teachers and my principals,
who were women, my pediatrician was a woman.
The mayor of Little Rock when I was a kid was a woman.
And so I just had such a profoundly different experience
than my mom had had when she was growing up
in suburban Chicago where most of her teachers were men,
the principals were all men,
the people that she saw in elected office were men,
any doctor or dentist that she interacted with was a man.
She just had such a different experience
than I did a generation later.
And so I think, yes, it was the power of my mother's example
and my amazing grandmother's examples,
and it also was just the world that I was growing up in.
And so I do think we have to continue
to have affirmative examples
of strong, amazing, persistent women
who have done remarkable things in many different fields,
because it matters to me
as the mom of a daughter and two sons,
that all of them look up to women.
I think it's really exciting for me that I see,
in my son, who's five,
if you ask him what an athlete looks like,
he talks about Megan Rapinoe.
That's what he sees as an athlete.
Partly 'cause he loves her pink hair,
and admittedly also 'cause he loves soccer,
and our American women are a little better
than our American men at the moment on the soccer field.
And so I see that it matters,
'cause I see it in my own kids.
Yep.
(upbeat music)